the prosecution did not allege that
chauvin killed floyd because he was
black
the prosecution did not allege racism
but that is what chovin stan's convicted
of that's what america
stands convicted of not just in the
court of law but in the court of public
opinion which matters a hell of a lot
more
than the court of law but there is one
thing that the jury didn't do
there is one charge that the jury never
even considered there was one charge
that was never even alleged
that chovan was convicted of and that of
course is the biggest charge of all
not the murder charge the charge that
derek chauvin
is emblematic of an american system of
racism
that charge was never proved no evidence
was brought to that idea
there was no there was not even an
allegation that this killing
was racial in any way that allegation
never was brought to court
there was no evidence presented of that
allegation
and yet that was the entire story if you
ask americans today
is derek chovan a racist i guarantee you
a majority of americans will say yes
and to what is the evidence of that that
george floyd died
that is not evidence of racism that's
evidence at best
of a bad cop it is evidence of bad
police procedure
it is evidence of recklessness that is
not evidence of racism
but we all know that the real charge
that was brought against derek chovin
because it was being brought against
america more broadly is that america is
racist and this case
is emblematic of that this data point is
all about america being racist he was
never charged with that
he was never accused of that no evidence
was brought of that but not only was he
convicted of that the entire country the
entire country was convicted of a crime
that was that there was literally no
evidence presented of
and that really is the part that that is
is terrible for the country
and has driven the narrative all along
because let us be real about this
if the if the body cam footage had
broken
at the time when it was supposed to by
the way the body cam footage broke well
after the original third-party footage
of what was going on with chauvin and
floyd if the body cam footage had broken
and the third-party footage had broken
and all of the evidence
had been cast into the public sphere if
all of that had happened
and there had not been 20 million people
in the streets declaring that america
was systemically racist
and that this case was a case of racism
it is highly doubtful to me whether a
jury would have convicted of second and
third degree murder on this evidence
which suggests to me of course that when
it comes to due process
this was due process in name it was not
justice in effect
because individual justice relies on you
evaluating the evidence before you
not on bringing in preconceived notions
about systemic american racism that were
never alleged in the courtroom the
prosecution
did not allege that the prosecution did
not allege that children was a racist
who went to kill a black man that day
that was not alleged the prosecution did
not allege that chauvin killed floyd
because he was black
or even that he was reckless because he
was black the prosecution did not allege
racism but that is what chovin stan's
convicted of
for the rest of his life that's what
america stands convicted of
in the view of the entire media in the
view of the entire democratic party
this was eminently political from
beginning to end
from beginning to end so when i say that
the jury is wrong
juries get it wrong but the question
isn't whether the jury got it wrong the
question is whether the jury got it
wrong because they were actually
convicting chauvin of a crime that he
was not even alleged to have committed
which is a standing in for america's
evil racist system
and the answer there is pretty obviously
yes
okay and you can see it in every element
of the narrative that's been trotted out
every single element of the narrative
for example felonies floyd
who is a relative that george floyd's
brother
got up and suggested standing next to el
sharpton one of the great race baiters
in american history
and jesse jackson another one of the
greatest race baiters in america
american history and benjamin crump
another great race-baiter in modern
american history
felonies floyd stood there and suggested
that george
george floyd was like emmett's till and
now for those who don't know about the
emmett till crime one of the great
racial crimes in american history emmett
till was a 14 year old black boy
who was falsely accused of having
sexually harassed a white woman
the white woman's family then went to
the place where emantel lived dragged
him out of his house
shot him and threw him in a river in
other words the circumstances
surrounding george floyd's death are
nothing
like the circumstances surrounding
emmett till's death which was a purely
racist murder
in the south in the jim crow era but
this is the comparison that was made
continuously and repeatedly is that
every day america's
racist system is creating new emmett
tills and george floyd is just the
latest example of this
here is philanese floyd making that case
the person that comes to my mind
is 1955 and to me he was the first
george floyd
that was that was immature wow
wow i did uh
was on cnn with deborah watts
and she just brought him back to life
people forgot about him yeah but
he was the first george floyd okay that
is a that is a lie
it is a by the way it is a slander
against emmett hill who is not in fact a
repeat criminal
who had held up a pregnant woman at
gunpoint and robbed her house
with her kid in the house he was not a
repeat drug offender who done jail time
he was not a person passing counterfeit
bills emmett till he was not somebody
who resisted arrest
he was not any of those things emmett
till was killed because he was a black
because he was a black boy living in the
jim crow segregated south and there were
white racists who murdered him
there's no similarity between the
emmett's and the george floyd case but
again that is what chovin was convicted
of yesterday
not just in the court of law but in the
court of public opinion which in america
matters a hell of a lot more
than the court of law and it's not just
chauvin who stands convicted of that of
course the idea from the entire
democratic party and the media is that's
the entire country that stands convicted
of that when it was not
even alleged based on evidence it was
not even alleged
and it seems to me that what happened
really here is that the jury took
allegations that were not even made and
then read them into the crime
derek chauvin had to be convicted of
second and third degree murder not
because the fact pattern supported
second and third degree murder might
have supported manslaughter but he had
to be convicted of second and
third-degree murder
or whatever charges they threw at him
frankly because he was a stand-in for
the evil history of american racism
and the current system of american
racial prejudice i hope you enjoyed that
clip from the ben shapiro show if you
did go ahead and hit that subscribe
button so you stay up to date with all
our future content